[Música]
en noticias económicas también hablamos
de la reina isabel segunda y de las
consecuencias que está dejando su muerte
para eso nos acompaña en nuestro estudio
daniela blandón daniela bienvenida
gracias madre clara y si bien deja
consecuencias el mundo económico en
reino unido continúa no es así claro que
así porque el portavoz de la nueva líder
conservadora listos aclaró que los
planes de congelar los precios de la
energía a partir del primero de octubre
siguen a pesar del luto nacional por la
muerte de la monarca el instituto
nacional de estadísticas también aseguró
que seguirá reportando información y el
banco de inglaterra por su parte anunció
que pospondrá hasta el 22 de septiembre
su reunión de la próxima semana en la
que se esperaban decisiones sobre tasas
de interés esta es la primera vez que lo
hace desde que se volvió independiente
hace 25 años bueno y hablando
precisamente de historia cuáles han sido
los momentos icónicos de la economía que
enfrentó la monarca pues de la reina
isabel segunda subió al trono británico-
a inicios de los años 50 en un momento
en que gran bretaña conservaba gran
parte de su imperio y estaba emergiendo
de los estragos de la segunda guerra
mundo con un racionamiento de alimentos
que todavía seguía vigente una austera
década que dio paso a los agitados años
60 y luego un liderazgo reformista de
margaret thatcher en los 80 uno de los
momentos que están más relevantes fue a
comienzos de los 90 después de que un
incendio devoró parte del castillo de
windsor isabel segunda desde entonces
decidió comenzar a pagar impuestos de
renta como cualquier ciudadano del común
dos años después
1994 inauguró el túnel bajo el canal de
la mancha que une a reino unido con el
continente europeo a la reina le tocó
ver enormes crisis también como la
recesión mundial de 2008 y 2009 y en
tiempos más recientes que enfrentó
económicamente la regla pues comencemos
por el 23 de enero de 2020 cuando isabel
segunda sancionó la ley del preside y al
día siguiente boris johnson el ex primer
ministro firmó el acuerdo para la salida
del reino unido- del bloque comunitario
justamente el mismo año de la crisis
sanitaria por el commit 19 y lo último
que tuvo que ver fue como reino unido es
uno de los países más afectados de la
región contra la porra la guerra el
inusitado incremento del costo de vida y
también una incipiente recesión hoy en
día de todas maneras reino unido- está
transformado en todo un centro
financiero y es la sexta economía
mundial ya pesar de lo bien que le va a
reino unido este aumento de los costos
de vida ha incrementado el debate sobre
cuánto cuesta mantener a la familia real
cuál es la respuesta claro y es que hay
quienes conocen a la monarquía británica
como de firma que es una empresa
familiar con el monarca como director
ejecutivo no deja de ser de todas
maneras una compañía financiada en buena
parte por los contribuyentes que entre
2020 y 2021 desembolsaron lo equivalente
a unos 100 millones de euros para este
fin este dinero que cubre los gastos
desde viajes y recepciones reales hasta
el mantenimiento del edificio y también
las fiestas de los jardines en los
castillos pero esta subvención soberana
también se compara con las utilidades
que deja con state que es una tenencia
de tierras y propiedades de la familia
real valoradas en unos 15 mil millones
de libras esterlinas y que reportó más
de 300 millones de libras en ingresos
netos el año pasado esto es una empresa
que no es propiedad del gobierno ni de
la monarca y sus ganancias son como una
compensación para los británicos daniela
y netflix suspendió temporalmente el
rodaje de la serie de crown muy
brevemente cuéntenos al respecto pues el
gigante de streaming argumentó que tomó
la decisión de no seguir rodando la
sexta temporada por respeto a la monarca
la popular serie basada en la vida de
isabel segunda comenzó a emitirse hace
seis años y en su nueva entrega prevista
para noviembre se iba a enfocar en el
legado de isabel segunda en el siglo 21
gracias daniela por la información y
ustedes sigan conectados con france24
porque tenemos más de la actualidad
internacional